uh we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to david p
here is a mind-blowing voicemail
with a hypothesis about how i didn't get
coveted but my girlfriend did as i
talked about last week i don't know that
anything in this voicemail is based in
science but it is an entertaining
hypothesis let's listen to it together
hey david i listen to your show on your
girlfriend with the coveted exposure and
i have a
possible solution for you
it wasn't an issue of her infecting you
with an issue of you infecting her okay
your brother and you share the same
genetics and all probability you picked
it up from your brother what i'm finding
here uh around me is that people that
have got high levels of protection
are still picking up the virus
and they can still extrude virus in
micro doses essentially is how to think
about it
extrusion of micro doses wow
but they're not producing enough
for the viral protein to trigger the um
cova test
so in your situation where your your
girlfriend seemed better than worse
better than worse type of situation
um what i think happened was your
brother infected you guys when you were
in the car when you went home her
genetics responded her way your
protection and genetics responded its
way and such a brother and you obviously
share the same so all of this is
absolutely fascinating and entertaining
i don't know that there's anything here
based in science so like one idea first
of all the idea that it's my brother who
was the exposure point my brother tested
tested tested after this and it doesn't
seem like he had cove it doesn't seem
like he had it nor that he got it the
other thing is
i don't know that there's any evidence
that if you're exposed by someone with
whom you share genetic material like a
brother that you're less likely to get
it from them than an exposure from a
person with whom you don't share genetic
material i i've it's it's endlessly
entertaining i just don't know that
there's any facts here very similar
so during that time frame you were sick
you weren't sick enough to actually
produce enough protein to trigger the
positive test she was remember the test
is looking at viral rna not viral
protein as we talked about yesterday so
there's some some question marks here
about this explanation reacting to that
because you guys both work from home and
you're both um in such a closed space
and you're living as a couple
you essentially were micro dosing her on
a regular basis
so it was a situation of very little
over a long period of time that's why
she had her ups and downs
it it it's fascinating i don't know that
there's anything there that's actually
backed by science but a fascinating
fascinating explanation on today's bonus
show the u.s russia talks have ended and
no progress has been made we will also
talk about the first ever heart
transplant from a genetically edited pig
fascinating and john ossoff will
introduce a bill
banning members of congress from owning
from trading individual stocks all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
sign up at
joinpackman.com and we will see you then